good morning Friday re it is Thursday
I have not filmed much this week again
because I've just been in a mode where I
don't knock down I can't really explain
it you know how you get mode really
excited to do things and you do them and
then you get in modes where you're kind
of lackadaisical about them depressed
about them is a little too intense of
words not in the mood and I wish I could
explain more than that so there's not
much filmed this week so I thought that
today Thursday I would just take you
along for my whole day you can see what
it's like right now it is almost noon
I just woke up let me explain all week
I've been going to bed at like 3 or 4
a.m. and then waking up at 7:00 or 8:00
or 9:00 a.m. to do this that or the
other and so I have been exhausted and
so today I gave myself permission to
sleep same way I've given myself
permission to not film anything for you
guys I did wake up earlier and eat some
peanut butter out of the jar for
breakfast there's that someone's walking
to my house hello let's make coffee or
espresso boy booty worn Amala game
morning a little I vlog is that it's
confusing when I do when I'm along like
this this is happy right now I'm
vlogging right now because I didn't vlog
all week so I thought today I would take
them through my entire day well we don't
know how to get up it I know I explained
this already that way and I don't
normally wake up at almost noon
today was a gift to myself because I've
been so tired all week yeah
today's gift to myself
me F
good morning wild beasts how are you
this morning did you sleep well
oh what a treat thank you for such as
delightful conversation carry on here's
some updates on this room because I know
you're so curious keep being curious
never stop being curious it's one of the
keys to living a full life look I got
this oversized light bulb and I hung it
there I had to figure out how to make
this rope thing look less like a noose
because this is the idea chair used -
then you get big ideas oh I got this rug
whoa and I think it fits in here pretty
low this is kind of a chaos palace right
now here's what's happening at noon 15 I
have a call with someone from hello
giggles because I'm doing some more um
press PR publicity interview type stuff
for grace and style the order pertain
you have in mind your style guide that
comes out there for a second available
for presale right now at Kerr style book
calm and then I am packaging up a bunch
of copies of the book to send to digital
buddies my friends in the digital space
that I want to have copies of the book
so we're gonna go to the office later
and do that yes look at this some of our
imperfections make us perfect so does
our [ __ ] this is the moment where
I've set my computer and I try impress
me as much as I can for having to
actually look at my email inbox well
look I've been with this hand thing that
I got look at that that cool gone milk
stand on each
the things I don't do on the intro is
that I can't imagine now as a 30 year
old being a teenager with all the
technology and all of the documentation
that happens but prettier and prettier
so I just did two phone interviews one
with hello giggles a grounding Stephanie
I'm one with a guy named Benji from GQ
Stephanie it was absolutely fantastic
and really sweet I'm excited for you
guys to read that piece Benji I talked
to him about ghosting which is this
thing online when you are dating someone
or texting with someone and then you
just stop texting you become like a
ghost in the conversation and so I had
to give my point of view on ghosting and
I don't have a strong point of view on
it so if you read an article in the
future about me talking about ghosting
um we'll both be in for surprises how
that comes out I guess what do you guys
think about ghosting huh have you done
that to people is that been done to you
what is the culturally appropriate
response or opinion about it now haha
these are the cards that I'm sending out
with my books to some digital
buddy-style
is a simple way of saying I showered
haha so let's get into let's get into
this face let's make it a face how do
people vlog all day every day I watch
Lily Singh's vlogs um life hack if you
want to be inspired by hard work just
watch Lily Singh's blog channel and the
amount of [ __ ] she gets done the day is
very inspiring Lily I watch your blogs
all the time because I am a creep
because I love consuming digital content
and because I am wildly inspired by work
ethic but people that blog everyday ah
foof kudos to you I feel like this is
very uninteresting let's put a face on
this face shall we go ha like an
espresso of the day 1:47 p.m. backs on
facts on facts on facts I didn't put my
face on my face yet I'm feeling very
Beetlejuice right now cool I've been
writing out these cards to people and
now I'm gonna put my face on my face
go to the office and write out some more
cards and package up some boxes I know
that seems like something when using
this the living proof or faked hair day
dry shampoo because it is the closest
dry shampoo to where I'm sitting right
now
and it's fine see the collective dry
shampoo is later today I'm going with
Chester to an awards show because side
effects a project that he did to produce
then that I was in for awesomenesstv won
a casting award so we are going to an
award show later tonight for that this
face on face action is basically like a
primer for a more developed face on face
action later tonight that beauty talk
for all of you that don't understand
beauty and for all of you they don't
understand Beauty grace and style they
are two pretending you have it look at
this
Cassie's on the cover Blogilates and
that's so she cool and I bought a nylon
magazine the other day and Michelle Phan
was on the cover of it and it makes me
so excited when cool things happen to
nice people it makes me very happy
and I express my happiness by looking
really distressed let's put a face on
the face look I just got a different
thing down here and it organized my
makeup this is a utensil holder for your
kitchen and I put on my lipsticks in
there and then this is a box top that I
just hot glued these compartments into
because i'm DIY AF hey DIY everyone is a
hung a hand hold on to I don't know why
but that part of the song always makes
me think of like you know it's dropped
into like a den of tigers and people are
trying to help me out Hart Amazonian
clay full coverage foundation I like
this we should have put some moisturizer
on it says I put paint on a piece of
sandpaper right now you know that fun
feeling
kaboom let's do a lot of this because
sleeping has been very infrequent oh yes
protect the house princess I got this in
an airport pharmacy when I was in
Australia it's Navy oh and I like it a
lot it comes with all the little tiny
tools that you need are you guys doing
what are you guys watch on the internet
lately oh that was my impression of an
internet narc it's like when a narc
comes to your high school and it's like
so what kind of drugs do you guys do
lately I mean like like and who to get
them from what kind of videos you guys
watch lately and like who is in that
boat I might have gotten out of hand
with
I broke that one got out of hand good it
let's put some bronzer on who like to
attack my face like a Jackson Pollock
painting there you go boo art culture
references Donald Trump etc bless up
Trump let's see we're contributing to
pop culture mascara
Too Faced better than sex today's the
day to GI t do this let's put on clothes
that are cleaner than the body tarps
that we currently have on well human
clothes outfit of the day how about
because of style this hat is from
Topshop this shirt is from Oh God at all
Urban Outfitters made well something
along those lines
these pants are from H&M these shoes are
from Zara maybe this is from a sauce I
don't know one of the things you should
know when doing an outfit of the day is
things about your outfit we all have
room for improvement that's how I know
that we're not artificial intelligence
robots that are going to take over the
universe
my goes for going to the office this is
how she lays all day to get so depressed
when we leave you're so cute
goddammit I'll be right back
hello welcome to the office space I am
writing out some cards have created a
workstation from yourself some boxes of
people that were sending books out too
and welcome to the space this you might
recognize from the grace Helbig show on
e it's a prop I realized we haven't
shown you much of the office this is
where we shoot all the episodes of not
too deep the I podcast and we'll be
shooting more of them this weekend with
some more guests that I'm very excited
about but let's take a quick tour of the
office shall we this is Hana section
here this is very Hana I brought this
from my house she doesn't even know it
yet and I brought this from my house
which she also doesn't know but I
thought it was very appropriate for her
workspace would you like to know the key
to Hana success it's um this collection
of stuff down here a wooden sword to
emoji pillows nap chat pillow groan my
drunk kitchen DVD No if you want to be
successful that's what you need this is
the Diane & Grace work area mostly Diane
these are more boxes that we will be
filling this is our cool casual hangout
area with some things that I brought
from home recently the henna memory
don't know about yet but hey guys if
you're watching this I brought this
stuff from home and put it here it's a
tiger head nipple mango I feel like it's
aesthetic 1/2 this orchid was recently
gifted to me by one Nikki lemo because
she was a guest on the podcast last
weekend and she is really into feng shui
which I am recently getting into so she
brought me an orchid because she's the
greatest human being ever look how cool
and casual and hip and fun I mean like
what are we BuzzFeed
here's mamrie sparcstation Wow
what Dutch let's see what's in our
fridge hey fridge to our very crib Wow
lots of nutrients Oh
mamrie puts her coffee creamer here in
our office refrigerator because that
motivates her to come to the office
because she can't make her coffee at
home and she has Girl Scouts coffee
creamer - oh my god who would be more
similar relatable ow
that's a little scummy and then there's
the place where the magic happens
bathroom goal
every time you sounds like a broken
dryer how but I'm gonna try and make as
much headway as I can and stuffing boxes
hey sexual innuendo and then I'm going
to see if I have time to run out and try
and grab an outfit for this thing
tonight because I have some things I
could wear but classically in girl
fashion I have nothing I want to go see
if I can speed shop and get something
because I also like to see that at the
game it's like shop till you drop that
game show or supermarket sweep for
clothing so I like to test myself I like
to like give myself unnecessary anxiety
that's a fun game okay we are rushing to
the mall to see what we can find
whatever happens I just need myself in
the future that's editing this who has
already experienced whatever the
situation is that's about that is about
to happen you had stuff at home you
could have worn you just chose to make
things more complicated
what is that person's license plate kid
in me you see that that person's license
plate says kid in me even kidnappers can
get novelty license plates they don't
discriminate okay no success if I make
something twin however ultimate success
in giving myself
less time to get ready so let's rush
home and get ready in our cloud of
anxiety and stress yeah
you're lucky
we're back at the award show and there's
a good air and I've already changed out
of those fancy clothes into normal human
clothes you just showing off you show
these scratching your body on the couch
showing off oh someone is showing off
okay oh just pushed me out
it was a casting award show the RTO this
is what it was called and it was a room
full of casting directors and they were
accepting awards for casting TV shows
and pilots and movies and theater
productions and all sorts of things and
it was really an interesting place to be
and one that I can't say I'd ever
imagine myself sitting in because it's
guessing directors used to be kind of
the bane of my existence in New York
when I was auditioning for TV and film
things but it was really interesting to
see their community and to see them be
so really passionate about what they do
and it gave me a brand new perspective
on life is about gaining perspective but
look at your jacket and side effects was
nominated for best casting in a digital
series it did not win but everyone's a
winner here okay ah she hates it she
hates artistic expression
I like Home Depot we came to Home Depot
as a late-night fun adventure
what hi bad days since it's all my
friends all my friends are even all my
friends are here we're leaving Home
Depot or did you get a bunch of stuff
too and it's a little project I'm
working on
cryptic guy from Home Depot and I'm
sitting back in this corner of my room
and I have an announcement that I get to
tell you which is very exciting not only
am i doing book tour for grace and style
the order pretending you have it in the
United States but I'm also doing a book
tour in the UK so excited couldn't even
look me in the eyeballs ah I'm going to
a bunch of places in the UK Liverpool
Manchester Leeds Waterstone Nottingham
monkey nice Cannes Cannes Monkeys
Cardiff and Bluewater shopping centre if
you want all the details and all the
information you can click the link in
the description of this video or might
be on the screen somewhere here but I'm
so excited to bring my body and my
odours to the UK they're more expensive
thing if you have not already please
please pre-order a copy of Grace and
style the art of pretending you have it
at Grace style book calm on Grace style
book calm you can click the link that
gives you all the information for the US
and the UK tours I'm so excited
soon soon I will be visiting all of you
of that come to the tour thanks um and
that's it
I hope that you enjoyed this Friday I re
it was this interesting to you subscribe
that's how you do it as I good that's it
we've talked a lot today so as always I
don't know mascara faces are always fun
everyone's mascara face looks like
they're trying to understand Farsi but I
just watch the first episode of The
Bachelor and their mom just walked out
of one of the limos as a contestant like
you and Dad are getting a divorce